we've mentioned the P equals and P
question a number of times now as as the
most important question in theoretical
computer science and we've said that one
way to formulate it is exactly to ask
whether there's an efficient that is
polynomial time procedure to test
whether or not a formula in
propositional logic is satisfiable now
why is that such an important problem I
mean you know we're not just logicians
and we want to know whether or not some
formulas satisfiable how did it take on
this enormous importance and apply to so
many fields and illustrating how you
could use a satisfiability tester to
factor efficiently is a good hint about
why it is that all sorts of things
reduced to Sat and why it in fact is
such a centrally important problem so
let's suppose that we have a
satisfiability tester and use it to find
the factor a number n now the
observation begins with how you use a
Sat solver is that you can begin by
writing a or observing that it's easy
enough to design a digital circuit that
multiplies that does arithmetic
multiplications in other words it's got
some number of bits reserved for an
input X say K bits and another K bits
for an input Y and it's got two K output
lines that produce the digits of x times
y you might need one extra digit but
never mind that
okay so this is a multiplier circuit
takes an X at a bit X in and a what K
bit Y in and it spits out the product
which is another 2k bit number and this
is not a terribly big circuit the naive
way to design it would use a number of
gates that was about and a number of
wires that was about quadratic in the
number K the it's easy enough to design
one of these things where the size is
literally bounded by five times K
squared maybe plus a constant and so
there's definitely a small polynomial we
can given the number of bits that I'm
working with it's easy enough to build
this multiplier circuit
now suppose that I have a way to test
satisfiability of circuits how am I
gonna use this multiplier circuit to
factor well the first thing I'm going to
do is let's suppose the number that I'm
factoring scroll is N and it's the
product of two primes P and Q those are
the kinds of ends that we've been using
in RSA and let me also observe that it's
very easy to design an end tester that
is a little digital circuit that has 2k
o input lines and produces a 1 on its 1
output line precisely when the input is
the binary representation of n so let's
attach this equality tester that does
nothing but ask whether it's being fed
the digits of n as input and it produces
an output yes for 1 for N and 0 if the
input pattern is an the digital
representation a binary representation
of anything other than and that's
another trivial circuit to build so we
put those two together and now watch
what happens um I'm gonna take the
circuit and set the first of the input
bits to 0 and then I'm gonna ask the Sat
solver the following question is there a
way to set the remaining input bits
other than 0 so I've set the first one
to 0 what about these other bits I mean
the Sat solver can tell me whether or
not it's possible to get a 1 out of this
circuit with the 0 there fixed so let's
ask the Sat solver what happens and the
Sat solver says hey yes there is a way
to fill in the remaining digits and get
an output one well what does that tell
me what tells me that there there is a
factor that starts with zero so let's
fix the zero based on the fact that um
it's possible for me to fill in the
remaining digits with the bits of
factors x and y that equal n okay let's
try to set the second input bit to zero
and see what happens well well as the
sat tester is it possible now to fill in
the remaining digits to get the two
numbers x and y that multiply and
produce
and therefore output one and a set set
the set tester says no this is an
unsatisfiable circuit you can't get a 1
out of it anymore that tells me that I'm
have to set the second bit to 1 in order
to have a factor that of n where the x
and y will multiply together to be in
all right fine go to the third bit ask
whether or not zero works the sat set
fester says let's say yes so then I can
fix here oh I now know the first three
bits of X and of course I go on and in
two case at tests I know exactly what P
and Q are and I have in fact found the
factors P and Q so that's wraps that one
up that's how you use a Sat tester you
just do this at tests to K times and
you've factored this to K bit number um
and of course if the Sat test is
polynomial and K then doing it to K
times just is also polynomial and K with
one degree higher higher
okay now the this has five bility
problem as we formulated was a problem
about formulas that as you wrote out a
propositional formula and asked whether
or not it was satisfiable and i'm
instead asking about satisfiability of
binary circuits but in fact as we did in
some early exercises you can describe a
binary circuit by assigning a fresh
variable to every wire in the circuit
and then writing a little formula around
each gate which explains how the input
wires to that gate are related to the
output wire of that gate and that little
formula explains that wiring of that
gate and you take the end of all those
formulas and you have a formula that is
describing the structure of the of the
circuitry and in fact the formula is
satisfiable if and only if the circuit
can produce an output one so we really
have by assuming that I could test
satisfiability of formulas I can
therefore test satisfiability of
circuits and therefore I can factor so
this is if that's a simple trick to find
a propositional formula that's equally
satisfying
both to the circuit if the circuit
produces output one if and only if this
formula of about the same size as the
circuit in satisfiable and that's the
last piece that I needed in order to
completely reduce satisfiability the
factoring rather to the satisfiability
problem and you can see that this is
actually a general method that will
enable you to reduce most any kind of
one-way function to a few sad tests